こんにちは中角た朝礼私は変わっていますがじつは思っています
うあああああ
いろんなガチャガチャ
あれよねーまあいろんなガチャガチャありますよそれはもうガチャガチャけっこう好き
でよくやるんですけどもーさいハッチャー謎がちゃんとカーン何言ってるかわからない
ガチャとかああいうのほうがいいと思うんですよねー
何が出るか分からないんでもその金額相当なものまたはそれ以下またそれ以上が入って
いるアーヤ e アドバンねーけどこれは共有せない方は見つけてしまった
それ何か小皿ですご覧くださいどうぞ
me
[音楽]
jr アーサー王じゃあ
今日撮ってたらしいよね曲を採ってたらちょっともう世界んですけどチャオ役に機構
ポップカラーですお疲れさんです
イケナイお元気ですかああすまんだした&ですね静岡んあるを見てねーなんかに
ガチャガチャがあったんですけど課金さんを呼ぶの顔がこうあったんですよ
はいっ
本拠数盗られました
[音楽]
多分とってないと思うんだろ
許す番地か何かで予感じゃねあのメーサー黒く塗られてしまうみたいのとか
ああ待った三走れっとりわけなあのーでもうするために僕ができることは何かというと
あのガチャをかざすことしかできませんって言ったんですけども何度ですね
1回
300円たかよー
pou dou dou
[音楽]
ブービー品
あった
あっはぁデー
今井だったぁー
[音楽]
ua ああああ持込方に前院卒が全然は何親分
私なんと悪くなんやったんですけど2台はからねしてきました
闘技2万円以上月で釣って来たんで結構あるんですけども私みたいなことも書いてあっ
たんで
ひょっとしたらアタリが入ってるちょっと知りませんあたりがあればスタートハッピー
なんですけども果たして日か議員さんの母もジョンっ
に使ったの近さまずを良いものが入ってるんだろうなぁ
もなくば俺がしばらく王よあと仕掛けていきました
僕ないでしょ普通に楽しみよしでは受けていきましょう
イベント大谷口に入って見えることだったんですけどもひょっとして入ってるかもしん
ないそんときゃすぐお店に行きます上げてきますじゃあねジョンテイマーズの疑問です
ね
主人公た方のて呪文ですねこれ普通に年で呪文好きなんで嬉しいですああ
ああああああ
あって結構いいねはいっていうとこれねすごいな売れず嬉しいですよね
この3 air bar ナビの看板か集英社なんつっこみって書いてあるな
グラデーションが頑張ってシラーじゃーん
老舗いいえ凄い凄い牛名作入ってますねー
じゃあ富津5位なんだねえっに300円じゃないかめちゃくちゃこれすごいぞポケット
また不思議なダンジョン闇の探検隊乗っちゃえばんですね
いやいいなんかノリうっううっちゃんとソフトも入ってるはこれすごいなあこれ4つに
すごい感動したああっ
いやあああちょっとかあああああなにこれええ多分ぬーっに版第壱巻キャンペーンです
ねこれですね
girl ドっぽいですねちっちゃい虫ピラー
ウルトラマちょっと嬉しいですねー
2 np じゃない方 a 誰これ
あっ輝だ秒機能なペっていうのでこれすごくないですかあキラーのフィギュアですよ
アキラのフェアなんですけども入ってたのが京都あのおばあさんですね
だーっじゃああるもんですねみーっ
みーっ
[音楽]
次行きましょうあーこれに母さんが中何か分からんと可愛い女の子とイヤホンジャック
だーっ
凛ちゃんだラベルりんじゃーんぐいぃぃーするめちゃくちゃでかいやつやーこっじゃあ
誰なんだろうな配球感あるんですけどあーいいですね fuck のバイクフルガール
のバイクが入ってましたねー
グルックラウラ目安です絶対チョコエッグのおまけカーはなよちゃんなにこれええ
善庵子マジでわからんこういうのが一番困りますねぇ
これ長崎のお土産だよこれかスペアくんです勘弁してくれますねほんとにやばい
やっぱこういう入ってんドカーン受付でさあどんどん上げていきましょう
さあクロスター
懸命るー
で待ってこれやばくねぇ俺そんじゃけどやばいでしょやばいやばいやばいキャッチでは
かなぁ
んよっ
一可愛いラブライブの凛ちゃんのキーホルダーですね h 可愛いんだかこれ一番
あたりから今んとこ
a
当てたことを押されなくマンシリーズガンダムとコラボする奴ですねこの昔なんか無駄
に集めてな気がしますけど気づいたら全部ナビだってました
あーなんでこれはなんかいろいろ言わ生集められてますね勘弁してください
love もまあちっ拉致でわからんん3個入ってるよ千住ちゃんヌードル
パックワールドの人の青いバージョン air
ああああああああ
一番の当たりたこれは誰がめっちゃ可愛いんだけどそして編み方も一緒だし何か
組み合わせかもしれないね
こちらかんこちゃーん泣いてるバージョン眼光坂道の嬉しいですなーこれをポットに
強いとだけものはスナックワールドの仏教
妖怪メダル3枚だ俺の知ってる悟空じゃありません
sap じゃない方ドラえもん妖怪メダル3枚
んあー
どこかで見たことあるようなないようなあっあああ
でなんで結構束にね僕の好きなキャラクターいると嬉しいですよねこれとかめっちゃ
可愛くない家7七宝ちゃんやめっちゃ好きだったからこういうのマジで嬉しいですね
じゃあ
けいおんのあずにゃんすごいすごいすごいなんかめちゃくちゃおりの. ripe の
みるきーかけのスヌーピー
ああーすごいなこれ登山2のガチャピンがだったマンニョ頃に入ってるのいいなぁ
無事部 ao スターウォーズ日本ラグビー選手のユニフォームバージョン
ドラゴンボールかんぱーこれでもおれしらねいつなんだよねああこれも凄いけどなぁ
xv もんですねああ
ぶーばいいんだけどこれめっちゃ出るなぁキノコですうーん知らんブーブメモ
ロサてめっすっ
ワールドの鍵めっちゃ当たりっぽい不意に出てるけどこれああさっきと同じやつですね
くまっこんーなんかすごい所でも需要ラマ風のミニカー
さあいよいよ少なくなってきましたが
[音楽]
辺りはどこだあたりがまだないぞ大根あたりが欲しいですお願いしますじゃあちゃんと
したすムービーだ
何かの缶バッツ星フォア背景の影山くんすごいすごいフィアットセンサーも企業だ
あああんん
なんか見覚えあるぞこれうーん
3酔う[ __ ]チャに私始めちゃってさゆいちゃん美味しいですよ
たときにどこかで見たことなるような魔女って
なんだこの組み合わせはアナグラムののんちゃんと金獅子
なんだこの組み合わせを a さっきのやつ誰だ何かなに見キャラクターなんだろう
なぁ分かりません
減税もフレンダーグレーいい
ています
ban
うん
[音楽]
me
バッハ